well let's let's talk about uh let's
talk about the media because you
mentioned this a moment ago ian check
this out
when you google search riots right now
my friends
those those of you who are not watching
just listening we know that riots
erupted in minneapolis
we know that people are scared the
jurors are scared
that if they give i think this was
expressed in the trial during jury
selection that if they say not guilty
for chauvin
it's going to say he's going to burn to
the ground what you need to understand
is it's not just about
whether or not chauvin gets freed or
goes to prison
there's three charges chauvin can be
acquitted on one
two or three or none and that means
out of all the potential scenarios and
everything we've seen
i would be willing to bet you will get a
headline that says derek chauvin
acquitted in the murder of george floyd
and then it'll say he was convicted on
this on third degree murder and
manslaughter but acquitted in second
degree and they use the most shocking
headline acquitted in the murder of
because they want you to freak out with
that
the media knows exactly what they're
doing and i can prove it
by simply go and and google i gotta say
whatever their system is whether it's
intentional not is totally in on it
right now there's riots happening in
minneapolis and guess what story you get
when you go to google and you type in
the word
riots there it is the first result out
of 17 million
nine hours ago the washington post
headline data about the capital rioters
serves another blow to the white working
class trump supporter narrative
what this was
three months ago they need the milk
i mean we just had riots the other day
yeah i mean there's been riots there's
been riots going on in portland
for a year a year like every night i
know that i've seen
stuff about it in the past month and
they're still talking about the capital
right
because because because the orange man
is
very bad ian don't you know
your point is made the orange man he's
very bad
and people cannot forget that he is a
very bad
orange man how is it that google
17 million results the top post it's
data about the cap and then underneath
it
people also searched for riots of
minnesota why would they search
could you imagine being in minnesota and
being like you're hearing bangs and
screaming and you're like what's
happening so you go on google type in
it's like
capital rights they go i don't care
about that it's ridiculous that you have
to specify
in the it is ridiculous that you have to
specify what riots
when it comes to a news po like which
ones
which is the ones that have been going
on in portland is it the one that
happened at the capitol is it the one
that's happening
i mean that's that's it's ridiculous
hold on
you ready for the best part sure i'm not
done give it to me i'm not done
give it to me the first post when you
search for riots it's not black lives
matter it's
capital riots then you have people also
searched for newsweek dw
and national review talking about
minnesota
but these aren't the results for riots
these are people also searched for
riot in minnesota google is letting us
know
these three results are suggestions not
based on the search term riots
and guess what the actual second listing
is
in the search term riots right now as we
literally
had riots yesterday well the first one
was the capital and the second one is
from cnn one hour ago
trump state department appointee facing
capital riot charges
released from jail what's the third
clear the capital pence pleaded
what's the fourth you're going to die
tonight body cam footage shows capital
riots
don't forget and then and then and then
and then number five tmz
dante write oh not newsguard tmz got it
right
tmz it is the fifth result right now
a day after the city was being ransacked
and looted and there's tear gas and
fires
they're still talking about the capital
three months ago
i suppose that it is fair to point out
that this speaks to your
a point that you've made multiple times
about the
media loving donald trump and losing
that
the the revenue that he generated for
them
yeah um because nothing nothing in
in the past 10 years has gotten clicks
like
you know the orange man being just why
aren't they
cognizant of this fact where they can
just say well we have to move on
you know so like what am i talking about
on my main channel tim cast
last year i'm like democrats republicans
election election laws what's happening
all very election related i get people
going like all you do is talk about
politics now you just talk about
cultural issues i'm like dude what are
you what's the big thing going on right
now
now we're outside of the election and
what am i talking about
shoving trial i've got like four out of
the past five videos about the chauvin
trial because this is the big impact
it's where the news is going it's
what's important i'm not talking about
trump trump trump used to be seriously
in like my
my my tags first word because like it
was always it was always trump it was
always something with trump
and even i was like geez you know i'm
tired you know this guy's suck up the
air
now we're in a new space there's news
happening people want to know what's
happening and what do you think about it
so for people come to me they're like
tim
tell me what you think about this
because most people already know what's
going on
you've seen the news article yourself
you talk to your friends about it
you go online to find commentary to
maybe think of something or hear
something you didn't think of yourself
i do this right so now people are going
and they're going to google and type in
riots what's happening enter the fifth
search result
was tmz and it was the first talking
about
dante wright do you know what the sixth
is
capital rider xypd cop stunned he's
being held with inner city criminals new
york post
it's not just the left the new york post
is a conservative
conservative outlet they're the ones
that broke the hunter biden laptop story
even then 11 hours ago amazing
and you know it's really funny the next
the next one is about kenosha
it's remarkable to me that if you search
for riots you are not getting served
information about what happened in
minnesota
and it's primarily because many of the
big mainstream news sources that
dominate search results
ain't talking about do you crosscheck
duckduckgo do you search with duckduckgo
over
no no i usually don't even use google to
find stories i you know go through
various news sources and i use twitter
and i kind of curate i can't get it up
on my phone i'm interested to see if you
search right on duckduckgo
that's a good point that's a good point
let me see if i can't get it up on your
phone
i don't know how to switch it in my uh
in my brave browser on the fly
i'll check into it though all right
maybe
goes i'm not saying i'm not blaming
google necessarily right
uh so the first result is recent news
massive rise in minnesota minnesota
riots clear the capital so the first two
in recent news
on uh go is minnesota
so it could be always hold on then we
get uh
general riot not even news so after
that's like definition of riot
not even news but let me click news to
make sure i'm being absolutely fair
right
number one when you go to riots all
duck.go massive rides in minnesota click
the news tab
the first result massive minnesota riots
massive rights in minnesota
the second one several minnesota
businesses looted the third cleared the
capital
so they still have some of these stories
but duckduckgo is prioritizing better in
my opinion
could be the google algorithm is just
tainted towards
trash bait you know flashbait or
whatever or it could be that larry and
sergey
are political i mean those guys run
alphabet they're basically the owners of
alphabet it's the it's the trash bait
um we know that google has a news source
ranking
where they like i think a bunch of
conservative
outlets don't appear in search
particularly bright brown i think
breitbart's like omitted
and we've i think we saw this leaked
actually i think it looks like veritas
or somebody leaked where it's like
here's the google blacklist
of all the websites they don't allow to
appear in search or are limited
for a while even my youtube channels
were and then it wasn't until on this
show i said hey my youtube channel is
our blacklist they removed it so i'm
like google must be listening they're
listening
but that's this is what's happening
google you don't
think it is i think it's like a toilet
being flushed and like all the turds are
being swirled towards
the middle so what happens is google i
believe
genuinely and from their own bias i'm
not saying they're i'm not saying
they're not doing things wrong i think
they think they're genuinely doing the
right thing they're like we gotta get
rid of this fake news
let's make sure we only prop up you know
cnn washington post msnbc cbs abc nbc et
cetera new york times
those outlets are then suffering their
ratings are collapsing their
subscriptions are down so they're like
just make trump trump trump trump so
when
we're three months out from from the
capital riots or protesters or
insurrection we're going to call it
they're still doing it because here's
what happens
like many of the grifters the people who
are
all about just pandering to the tribe
the news outlets built up an audience
of angry establishment democrats and
leftists
if they come out now and say something
they're worried they will lose money
so they're like they're they're probably
sitting there i've been in these
editorial meetings
i imagine they all sit down and they're
at the table and there's someone on the
phone some editor or some boss
like okay so what are the stories that
we got and they're like well we had
those riots yesterday in minnesota and
they're like
well you know um we haven't got a
resolution yet why don't we hold off on
that one
we can talk about the capital you know
some of these guys are getting arrested
capital's great let's talk about the
capital
and what what you don't hear in the
actual words which what underlines this
is the boss going if we talk about
the minnesota stuff we're gonna piss off
a lot of our subscribers and lose money
capital now that's that's that's money
and that's safer for us
let's go with that one yeah i mean that
seems like a reasonable take
um especially considering um
a lot of the the more progressive news
outlets are run by people that are
not as interested in progressive uh
issues as they are in the bottom line
you know
when siding with your uh siding with
your
audience is the primary driver
you know you don't want to you don't
want to focus on things that will
upset them or or drive them away do you
think they they were like well there
were riots so let's write a story with
that flash word
in it and then so they they said okay we
got to write a story about riots because
riots are popular right now there's
going to be a lot of riot search results
so then they pick the the most trashiest
riot and they're like let's write about
the
january 6th or is it just i've been
writing about that crap anyway
i hadn't thought about that but maybe
they do um
i i would i think that i would look
uh in the next couple days to see what
happens
if that if if there are a lot if there
continue to be because
they didn't know that there were going
to be riots today two days ago and some
of the stuff that tim was pulling up was
from
you know uh you know yesterday or the
day before or whatever the riots
are have started off today i believe so
or at least the ones in minnesota
because of the uh
the cops bad shoe would you like to play
a game
yes i would like to play a game so i
pulled up two progressive sources
okay it's not this is not science this
is just me pulling up two progressive
sources
then msc msnbc and fox news to see what
they're talking about
and it's exactly as i thought first we
have slate.com
what's their headline story inflation is
about to look freaky
slight.com is a leftist publication you
think they'd be talking about something
we got over here a small little you know
blurb on the left
is derek chovin's defense flailing the
answer to that question is no by the way
but uh the big story isn't about
minnesota
in fact i don't even think i see
anything on minnesota all right okay
well slate's up the biggest
let's try vox vox vox.com okay let's
jump over to vox and what do we see
for the main number one story the
hottest number in conservation is rooted
more in politics than
science why the u.s egg industry the
christian right
the chauvin trial feels momentous
georgia companies banning together
natural-born citizens biden's plan the
bizarre push where's the minnesota riots
okay okay okay hold on now fox news now
we know
fox news going to be talking about the
riots rupert murdoch
all right pull up fox news the top story
is city manager fired for demanding due
process for cop
in deadly shooting mayor takes control
of police
okay so we got dante wright from fox
news it's actually
i don't i wouldn't say it's right biased
but they're just saying the cop demands
due process and got fired
that's fairly neutral but they are
talking about it not talking about in a
positive light right
i mean sort of the consequences no it's
just that nowadays the constitution
is a right-leaning uh issue it's not
like okay the left doesn't give a crap
about the constitution
all right well just below this on the
front page of fox news
bracing for violence live updates
curfews and effect across minnesota
crowds swarm nyc streets
all right well the two progressive
sources weren't talking about it at all
fox news is now what do you think msnbc
has to say
uh nothing good and msnbc top story
yamachi yamashi alicendor dante writes
shooting as a recurring nightmare for
black americans
it's exactly what i thought it was going
to be i thought the progressive outlets
would
probably blurb this somewhere but not
really talk about it
and the big networks were going to
choose their position
fox news this is bad prepare for
violence
msnbc it's a nightmare to what's
happening not referencing the nightmare
for everybody else as their city burns
so you know what i like to say when i
you know
i guess one thing i can give credit to
what we do here
i tweeted the cop should be in jail like
like i already said whatever comes out
of that gun that's your responsibility
i'm not saying murder charges because i
don't think that's not going to stick
there was no intent but she screwed up
and i had a bunch of lefties saying your
followers sure are going to hate this
one tim and i'm like
i don't care people don't know
people that aren't aren't involved in
the the gun world at all they don't
know how people that are involved in the
gun world think um right
they're good good i was going to say
conservatives i think who are more
concerned about black lives matter and
rioting
are going to be less pro 2a libertarians
who are very very staunchly pro 2a and
not big elder change just libertarian in
general
are going to look at this and be much
more about gun rights yeah if you're pro
2a
especially if you're a young younger
person that's pro 2a
the idea of of being exclusionary when
it comes to your
pro second amendment uh attitude that is
that is
old person stuff that is that is that is
fud talk
you know like seriously that is that is
that is
not what you see when you talk to people
that are pro 2a nowadays
you're saying they want it across the
board it's it's a very inclusive
inclusive thing you've got people like
match terrain you've got people like
colleen noir out there
uh you know really representing uh you
know
representing black people that that have
just as much love for
the the gun world as uh as anyone else
or
as any white people do so if you if you
tell me
that this dude you know in in uh
dante wright was a violent criminal who
should be in prison all that stuff i'm
like i don't think you're actually pro
too i think you're just a tribalist
if you say look man he shouldn't have
resisted arrest the cop i understand
what happened
i agree you're right however he should
be allowed to have his gun yeah
it shouldn't have been an issue in the
first place so but here so we'll
and we'll just reiterate this point
because for this segment
dante wright should have just been
arrested he should have put his hands
behind his back
and then someone could have advocated
for him yeah because then they would
have been like is the only thing he's
being charged with is that he was
carrying a gun
i'm pretty sure the second amendment
says the right to keep and bear arms
will not be infringed
what is his crime and then you sue he
would have had standing to make a
challenge maybe up to the supreme court
and then it would have been exonerated
it would have made the whole country
better for everybody
should never resisted he shouldn't have
been criminalized in the first place for
his right to bear arms
so it's a layered thing it is but uh you
know long story short
this is what we get from the media
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you